Let's uh to keep this like existential
crisis going go on I felt it I fell into
like another weird Rabbit Hole the other
day all right what would you do if you
knew you were about to die
because okay what what span of time are
we talking are we talking like I'm gonna
die within the year or I'm gonna die
like tomorrow uh within like an hour
yeah oh [__] because because I I
um I got into the video yeah because I
got into this weirdo
I'm having the last knot
I am the one who has the laughs
because I because uh like I uh got into
this rabbit hole because I like this uh
this video was recommended to me about
the Hawaiian like kind of like the fake
missile alert right so uh a while ago
like Hawaii had like a fake missile
alert where everyone on their phones got
on got an alert that said ballistic
missiles are heading towards Hawaii
right please head to shelter as soon as
possible this is not a drill
and of course terrifying it's it's like
imagine like the earthquake alerts it's
like on that except
basically you're being told that a
nuclear bomb a nuclear problem nuclear
ballistic missile bomb is heading
towards Hawaii right an island where the
[__] are you gonna run yeah where are
you gonna run so four battles yeah so
for about like 45 minutes
a lot of people believed
This is the End right this is this is
going to be the end and like I I saw
that video and then I I was just it just
like so curious so I started like
reading comments and hearing stories
about people who actually experienced
that and it's just it's interesting just
to see people say like you're you're
[__] brain chemistry just had their
brain chemistry had changed after that
experience just because they had like
made peace
with the fact that they were going to
die and it's I find it interesting
because you know in movies and
everything like that you you see people
portrayed as the world's coming to an
end let's all [__] Panic let's all go
out kicking and screaming but the
reality is so many people were just
um were just kind of like at peace
without accepting yeah yeah I I think
about that video of that guy who's just
playing golf oh yeah yeah I'm gonna
finish this whole of golf yeah I'm gonna
get a PB before he like I saw that video
as well there's a guy who just starts
off the video being like if you're
seeing this video I probably didn't make
it oh wow and and he just he just starts
being like you know what I lived a good
life this is probably the end but I'm
gonna finish playing this golf I'm gonna
go out doing what I have it's such a
good video what a chat what a [__] I
think I think one of the most famous
stories actually uh Jim Carrey who was
in Hawaii at the time all right uh and
he I saw a clip of him telling his story
about it as well well what happened was
he got a call from his agent being like
this is happening
what the [__] uh so you know the first
emotion you get is like Panic yeah is
there anything I can do I gotta find my
friends gotta find my family and
everything like that
um so he tried calling his daughter I
don't think his daughter picked up or
anything like that uh but then but then
after after that initial panic's over
kind of like the acceptance kind of
comes in so then what he did was he just
he just thought to himself everyone's
trying to get out but then he just he
just said he just realized he didn't
want to die in his car right so he
walked out to the hotel and just walked
on the beach and just sat there and just
thought about everything that he was
thankful for in life and I'm like [__]
man that is that must have been an
experience that you can't like I don't
know I don't know it's
more people like I'm genuinely curious
if anyone in Hawaii
went through that experience what was
your experience because I I find that
what happened in Hawaii [__]
fascinating because it's it's kind of
like a case study of like so many people
believing that this one terrible thing
is going to happen there's one thing you
only see in like films and Cinema and
stuff like that so you don't normally
you don't really know how people are
going to react or how how you're going
through around you you can only just
like [__] think maybe I'll do this
right maybe I'll do that right and I
feel like hearing those stories as well
like you know you know first-hand
narratives is like you know they you can
you can hear and you know imagine what
they were going through but like the
actual like raw emotions that they were
going through is like that's something
you can't just like listen to and
imagine right like that's something
that's just like you need to have
experience the amount the amount of
comments I saw that was uh when I knew I
was going out I just started smoking a
fat blunt man I was I was going out high
as a guy baby
and I'm like and I am doing every strong
imaginable before I go I will not die
sober
no no that's a good question like what
would you do
I don't know what I'd do try and break
every lore imaginable in an hour try and
break every law imagine just just do
something be like you know like like
every dark thought you have right it's
like you know I'm sure there are people
who are like well if we're gonna go in
an hour yeah I might as well try and
fulfill that more curiosity
I'm eating one I don't care if it's raw
okay I I I want to go out eating good
food now I've been thinking about okay I
have 45 minutes to find my perfect Last
Meal which is available in the vicinity
I'm in what the [__] what would I go
with honestly McDonald's
assuming that the workers are happy to
keep working when the world is ending in
45. you got to clock out no yeah do you
know how many people want Big Macs right
now I gotta give it to them
it's it's probably they're probably just
giving it away yeah exactly but I want
it I want it I want to know if there's
anyone who's like anyone who [__]
confessed enough
there's probably someone out there but
also if if you're if you're dying and
then if the other person's dying does
confessing help at all like I don't know
because we've never been in that
situation but
what's kind of funny to think about is
like they confess right yeah and then
they didn't yeah and they didn't so they
basically just [__] themselves okay can
we google if there's any stories of this
happening I'm sure there must have been
people who like P.S piece of [__] all
along yeah I [__] on your paws I wasn't
the dog P.S I I banged your mom
I want to know the wholesome stories but
also I want to know what was the most
wildest [__] that was like that happened
during that 45 minutes [__] [__] yeah
yeah I'm sure yeah some people only have
like an hour left to live I'm I mean
some people already did break laws oh
I'm not sure yeah some people pretty
dead and probably got in trouble for it
yeah
Jesus but they barely parted a movie
you wouldn't steal and steal a college I
will
not breaking him if I had a year to live
well I'm starting a meth Empire yeah I
hope one of you boys would be you know
my my Hank to me to me Walton white I'd
like to think so
yeah exactly it's like depending on the
that's why I was asking about the time
frame right because it's like okay if
it's like an hour right there's only so
much you can do but like say for example
if you were gonna die within the next
like say a month yeah right like I think
it would be very different I decided
I've decided what I want to do well if I
had an hour left I would film every
single hot take I have left that is
unsayable out loud and then I'll post it
and then I'll die